The low fat he recommends is not really low, just low comparison to keto. He said keep fat around
30%, which is higher than than you were thinking. In the article he clarified the simple versus complex
carbs and people with typical gut microbes from standard American diet, the complex carbs are not
digested well and create endotoxins. So start with simple carbs like fruit juices and then you get
really healthy microbes, switch to the complex carbs so I'm talking about still plenty of healthy fat
plus some complex carbs mostly vegetables or berries. Still a bit unclear are your feelings
about trying to boost NAD, mitochondrial health does high homocysteine come into play
with this extra B. So the extra B is actually going to lower homocysteine levels. So
the NAD again just taking you know boosting too much NAD on a constant basis again does help
mitochondrial health in the in in an effect. So let's make sure we
not really increasing mitochondrial health. You're just giving the mitochondria where you produce
glutathione. So you're just giving building blocks for glutathione in the mitochondria. You're not
really, you know, they're not mitochondria are getting healthier because you're doing that.
So, but you just got to be careful in keeping if cancer cells utilize that it's helping keep
cancer cells alive. So that's where we do it a rotational type diet can be beneficial not stayed on
some one specific thing unless we test you for it. That's why getting cheek swab tests on a regular
basis then we can tweak things and see what works for you, what's working for you. That's why
you know even I don't try not to take a dogmatic approach even though sometimes I speak that way
to apologize but I'm trying to to do an individual approach for everyone as best as we can.